[Music]
is that yes it
is what the hell were you doing you're 3
hours late dad you don't understand the
car was busted so we had to shred why
your lips red were you eting a snow cone
it's a really good guess what kind of
adults were all BL the police are here
and they're saying that you bought
alcohol for miners thanks Boys in Europe
the drinking ages like 10 they could
have been European what made you think
they were European they had a certain
Gena quality I think one of them was
eating pant on
shakala guys everyone thinks we're
losers but that's about to
change I know where The Treasure of
Foggy Mountain is from when we were kids
we are looking at 100 Mil $100 million
it'd be like I mean I know it's more
than this but at least a million dollar
each significantly more what are we
waiting
for the cute guys that came in earlier I
didn't see nobody cute the ginger look
like a colonial ghost glasses look like
Tim Burton Drew him and in a short one
we probably were the same size bra they
had a treasure map with like an x on it
we going to steal that
map that is a full on Hawk hey buddy
Traverse it Traverse The
Rock does it not know it can fly why did
it walk away with an attitude everyone
is after this
treasure we deserve that you deserve it
yeah three white guys whose biggest
issue is what growing up no feel like
it's more nuan
you just hit a woman I apologize for him
I for one would
never oh my God so I've hit one woman
that's not in the
grand welcome new friends we can all
agree this is a scary call and we're
waiting for the other shoe to drop we're
in a docu series and this is episode two
dude
completely insane night guys why are we
tied
up I'd rather die than live without you
boys
holy oh
my guys look dude that's that's the
treasure door open
it I would be sick I would be sick to my
stomach forget the money it's not worth
it